>> That was right, David. So note what happened.
There were the contents of the working memory. Here were all the rules of
a level in the procedural part of the long-term memory. And so then,
match the contents of the working memory with the antecedents of the various
productions. Depending on the match between the contents of the working memory,
and the antecedents of the rules, some rules got activated,
fired as some people say. Depending upon what rule got fired,
that resulted in, perhaps, firing of additional rules. So as David said,
if the rule number one got activated because the goal became intentionally walk
the batter, that then lead to the activation of rule number three,
which was to select the intentional-walk operator. In this way,
given the set of contents of the working memory and
a mapping between those contents and the antecedents of the various production
rules that capture the procedure knowledge. Some rules get activated, and
this activation continues until sort cannot activate any additional rules.
At that point, sort has given an answer, based on the consequence of a rule
that matches a motor action. Note that sort just provided an account of
how the picture decided on a specific page, on a specific action.
Note that, we're started with the goal of providing an account of
how the pitcher selects on an action or how an AI agent selects on an action.
So what is the account? Based on the goal and the percents, match them
with the antecedence of the rules that captured the procedural knowledge.
And then, accept the consequent of some production that matches some motor
action from some precepts we have gone to some action.